hi i'm jennifer hudson and this is
rotten tomatoes becoming
[Music]
i found so many things about her
relatable
and i gathered that throughout like
doing my research
portraying her and also getting to know
her and to have her be a part of my life
which again is amazing
that's the beauty of her like the human
most of all she's a beautiful spirit
and then to know the position she took
using her power to make a difference
in the world through her music through
her artistry i think it was extremely
impactful for not only myself but for
everyone and i think that's why she is
so
dearly treasured by all like aretha's
universal
who gets to know the queen of soul first
of all aretha has always been
one of my idols musically and as a black
woman
as a figure in so many ways so to have
her manifest in my life
is already a dream and then for her to
say
she wanted me to play her which was a
dream of mine to do
it's so beyond me i can't even begin
to put it into words but it's something
i do not take lightly
and i will always honor and work for
like for the rest of my life it would go
far beyond the film for me
okay find out what it means to
me you really like it everything was
intimidating it's
it's like oh my god i don't think i
would have been able to get through it
without
having her voice in my head saying i
want you to do this
and that is the little thing that nudged
me on and said okay well
if i gotta go well i'm gonna go because
aretha said jennifer
i want you to play me so i felt as
though she must have felt i had
something within me
to offer to be able to portray her so i
held on to that
everything she does is just beyond life
to me
so it's like oh goodness and then the
psalms are all classics
and all dear to all of us and i'm the
kind of likes everything to stay in his
true context
so it's like well what can i do to add
to it
that i bring to the table but oh we need
to keep this in its
its condition its context as it is so
that was tricky
to be able to do but i mean i just tried
to do it all out of love that's all i
can say
we love it riri
by this new chick named aretha franklin
and like capturing
the essence i would like to call it the
capturing the essence of aretha
is allowing whatever influence she had
on me to come through me versus
mimicking her or trying to recreate
everything she did because you can't do
that it's only one aretha franklin no
one understands it more than me
but to pay homage to it to pay homage to
her legacy
and to use her nuances or the way she
would approach a song
like our voice is similar in certain
ways but they're built differently our
instruments so it was like okay how do
we blend the sounds
but i think longest kept the the just of
her faith
and then sang from the soul which i
think we both do
and keep it honest i think that was the
bridge that was the thing that ty
ties it all together and so i just tried
to say as true to that as possible
and just let her influence on me come
through
[Applause]
you're not about to mess this up for me
[Music]
clint ramos over costuming oh my god we
started out with 82
costume changes but it eventually
dwindled down to 50 but
it was so important because the costume
helped tell the story it
also helped me connect more to the
character and it taught me
more about aretha it made me feel the
regalness the royalty
you know of the queen of souls so it
helped a lot in a lot of ways because
the costume is a storyteller as well
and so it kind of helped a lot it
brought us to the era of the time
and costuming did not miss a beat and we
had such a good time with every costume
change
every week changed and it's just amazing
so that was a
a fun fun fun part of being aretha
honey find the songs that move you until
you do that
you ain't going nowhere
recreating the live performance from
aretha franklin's amazing grace album
it felt spiritual on the set although it
wasn't a set to me
it was church and i wanted to experience
it just as she did
it's like you can't really script church
so it's like roll the camera
and i also wanted to experience
each performance of each song as she did
so
whatever she did live in life i did live
on the set
and amazing grace was one of those
things and it's like we just let the
camera roll and
let the spirit of use us and you know
obviously keeping the blueprint of
amazing grace
by aretha in mind but living in that
moment
as you would do in church and it's part
of both of our roots
both hers and mines
how is aretha doing
all right what i want is i know we all
have a respect for ms franklin but by
the time you see this film
i want people to walk out with a
newfound respect for her and so to me
that is
that's that's the goal and i feel as
though it was in her voice
and what i took away from it it gave me
more power within my own voice and
wanting to use it
and so i hope that inspires others the
way that it inspired me you have to
disturb the peace when you can't get
no peace
you